hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of the last day of the ftx crypto
cup uh it is the armageddon game and
this is the seventh game
of day two so so far if you've been
following what's been happening in the
first match magnus started with a win
then uh wesley retaliated and the other
two games ended in a draw so the first
match
was a draw and now whoever wins the
second match uh will be
uh the the overall winner so magnus has
the white pieces and like i said this is
an armageddon game in this match also
magnus started with a win
uh with the the white pieces then wesley
immediately retaliated
and then two of the games were drawn now
the third game was a kind of a fighting
draw in the fourth game with just a
a repetition of moves in the openings so
neither of them really wanted to play
uh and uh try and force something they
they would rather
go into tie breaks and play two blitz
games so in the blitz section
i was a bit different uh there were no
wins with the white police uh white
pieces
uh magnus one with the black pieces and
then wesley again retaliated with the
black pieces or maybe
let me just check i think wesley won the
first one uh
just a second
uh yeah wesley won the first one
and then magnus retaliated in the second
one
and now it all comes down to this this
is the armageddon game and india are in
armageddon and there are different kinds
of armageddon but in this one
magnus has the white pieces and he gets
five minutes on the clock but he has to
win the game wesley gets four minutes on
the clock
uh there is no increment and the wesley
can even draw the game to win the
the match and uh uh wesley was the one
that shows the black pieces here
so like i said i'm a bit late to the
party so i'm only going to be covering
the armageddon game
i hope you guys enjoy it and uh i'm i'm
not sure if
if you've seen but i did post it on some
of my social networks
uh as of yesterday i became a father uh
so that's why i didn't record any videos
we were kind of busy
and uh i just want to let you guys know
that so
might be it might be i might have to uh
switch my handle for from my
mother to our father but we'll still
consider that one
uh so that being said uh let's uh let's
check out the game yeah everything is
fine she's
very very healthy and you know fully
operational and yeah she was born a
month uh
before due date but uh uh it seems that
uh yeah
there are no problems so that's uh
that's always great
uh in case you were wondering so now
getting back to the match
magnus with the white pieces opens with
e4
uh we have e5 by wesley knight to f3
knight to c6 and again
bishop to c4 so magnus banking
everything on this
uh joko piano we have knight to f6 here
wesley probably avoided bishop to c5
because he knew that magnus would
probably go for the evidence gambit
because this is a such an important game
so here he played knight to f6
and now d3 uh we have bishop to c5 by
wesley and
now magnus castles we have h6 and now c3
so preparing b4 a4
uh just normal development knight b to
d2 rookie one knight stiff one knight to
g3
uh and so on so here now we have castles
by wesley and
now b4 uh we have bishop to b6 and
a4 now trying to trap the bishop with a5
so wesley has to play a6
and not knight b to d2 so this is all
very standard stuff and none of this is
is new
we have d6 in the now rook to e1 by
magnus wesley shifts the knight over to
e7 now the knight can come for example
to g6 then later on to f4
and here there are some games where
bishop to b3 was played but here
we have d4 and it is now as of movie 11
that we have a completely new game so
let's see how wesley deals with this
uh he trades once in the center we have
caltra's captures and now he strikes
with
d5 but now uh magnus took like i think
like second uh
to give his reply and of course he just
went e5 and here wesley really started
thinking
and you can't really uh allow yourself
all that much thinking because
uh well you start with a minute less uh
uh
as this is armageddon wesley had four
minutes on the clock when the game
started
uh and there is no increment so the
thinking here is
not the way to go especially not in in
the opening so here we have uh
attacking the knight here and now knight
to h5 by way so you have to move it
somewhere you could go to e4 you could
go to d7 you can go to h5
uh there's really not all that much time
so wesley decides knight to h5 could be
a good move
i mean it's just as good as any other it
would seem
and magnus brings the bishop back he
tucks it in for later bishop to f1
seems like a very passive square but
this bishop
has saved many many games
and not only is it a good defensive
piece you can also just bring it back
for attacking purposes very quickly
later on so here we have knight to
f4 now it's possible because the bishop
no longer controls the f4 square
and knight to b3 now by magnus we have
knight e to g6 now defending the f4
knight
and now a5 pushing the bishop back
bishop to a7
and only now magnus trades here he gives
up his um
dark square bishop for this bishop
captures knight captures and queen to d2
so he uh kind of developed his bishop
and the queen and now connected rooks
and now this all comes with tempo as the
knight here on f4
is under attack so knight back to g6 and
now
knight to c5 and this is now i wouldn't
call it a monster night
just yet it is an extremely strong night
but maybe not a monster night just yet
uh and uh well it can be captured at any
point so here we have f6 by wesley
uh trying to challenge magnus's strong
structure here in the center
and now a magnus could go for something
like e6 and it does make sense since the
knight also covers this square
uh the problem is if you go e6 now then
rook e8 and now
for example whatever you do you can
always if you play bishop to d3 now
attack the knight
then the knight can come to f8 and
that's a great square for the knight
also
putting more pressure on the e6 pawn so
here magnus takes advan
advantage of wesley weakening the light
squares and he plays bishop to d3 right
away attacking the knight here so
you have to move it somewhere the
problem is uh if you move it now then e6
comes and now it's uh
it's uh well it's it's a different uh
position the knight really
doesn't have any good squares in the
future and black
is without a plan here so instead wesley
tries f5 seems a bit better because well
you grab more space and the the knight
can remain here but now
bishop to c2 by magnus uh we have rook
to e8 now
and now g3 just controlling this knight
here
saying that the knight will have no
squares in the future uh and now wesley
for the lack of a better move decides to
capture you could maybe waste some time
with some like queen to e7
uh but he wants to eliminate the
defender of these squares and
try and at least try to develop his
light square bishop so bishop captures
on c5 with b
captures in c5 and now bishop to e6
uh nicely developing but um it's uh
more of a pawn than a bishop right here
on e6 so here we have rook a to b1
as the target has presented itself and
rook to b8 now defending we have rook to
e3
now magnus can shift the rook over to b3
to put more pressure on the
b file and it's always a problem with
this b7 pawn because the a pawn and
the c pawn really make it just uh
everlasting backwards pawn you're never
pushing this anywhere
so here we have knight the e7 and now
rook eat the b3
threatening to just win material here
wesley defends it
you could also try with the bishop but
um it's
it's not it's not much better there's uh
there's really nothing you can
uh do here now it's just the the rooks
are completely cut off
from the game the queen does nothing the
bishop also
not all that impressive you could go
some like knight h4 put more pressure on
the f5 pawn
and just continue mounting pressure
later on you're going to play queen e3
you're going to put it upon the e6
and uh good things will happen uh so
instead
after this rookie to b3 we have queen
here uh wesley deciding to keep the
bishop on e6 and now comes knight to h4
so everything is nicely defended now
this is defended this is defended uh
the the g6 square is defended and now
magnus goes uh
uh sorry uh wesley goes rook to f8 now
so uh if you can get f4 in maybe maybe
you will still have some chance but if
you just wait and
and hope that magnus will lose in time
or something
uh then it's not gonna be uh well uh
it's not gonna be a great game for you
so here we have knight the g2
also a possibility because now the
knight also covers the f4 square
and bishop back to d7 now uh we have h4
by magnus now bishop to a4
finally the bishop comes alive but
magnus doesn't really care
he has other plans he pushes the rook
back to b2 we have captures on c2 queen
captures and now
knight the c6 so it seems that wesley uh
has
had some success in in developing at
least the knight here
uh now attacking this pawn now maybe the
queen will be able to move but you
always have this b7 pawn hanging and
there
if you allow this to be captured then
it's just game over so here we have
queen to c3
magnus just defends this uh and says
okay what do you play here
uh and wesley has a couple of a couple
of ideas he could play something like
knight to e7
uh and just wait uh but then for example
knights to f4
and it's really a problem now the knight
has to be here defending this pawn
and if you try something like c6 then h5
and now all of the squares
have been taken away from black you're
you're again going to play the rook to
b6
uh and just start taking away more
squares uh
from from black's pieces so it's just
going to be a very very slow and painful
death
after queen to c3 however there was also
this very very nice
f4 move and it's maybe the kind of move
you have to play if you want to
stay in the game uh for example after
knight captures you're going to play
queen to g
for now saying that okay now i'm i'm
going to play rook captures on f4
because the g pawn is pinned and also if
you move the knight
then my queen and the knight are
attacking the pawn and this is the
uh the base of your pawn chain if i grab
this it's going to be great the problem
is you can just defend with queen e3
you guard this knight and now you give
up for example the a5 pawn so now knight
captures on a5
knight captures on d5 and you maybe uh
maybe you would have more success
playing this now
you do have a past a pawn and b but it's
still a very very hard position to play
so what can be done here uh and also
yeah if knights the c4 just attacking
the queen
and the the rook you don't gain anything
because queen b3 and now if the rook is
captured now you have a beautiful
discovery here knight to f6
check wins the queen so there are
um a lot of possibilities here but it's
a blitz game with no increment of course
it's uh
not possible to see such things uh but
uh we will mention them if
if they are uh interesting such as this
one so here
uh wesley didn't go for for the uh f4
idea he didn't go for the like knight to
e7 a waiting move he went uh
g5 so he started he he said i'm gonna
i'm gonna really go active here so here
magnus played h captures and g5 we have
h captures on g5
and now f4 uh making room for for the
king and now you can move the king to f2
and you can start bringing your
rooks into the game so here uh if you
capture then we're just gonna
play knight captures on f4 and again
it's a really really bad position for
black the rook is coming into the game
uh the queen can also join uh
very easily and it's just going to be a
very nice attack against the black king
there's not much you can do here so
instead after f4 we have king to g7 now
wesley wants to counter the rooks and
the h file he knows of course what
magnus is planning
king to f2 and now comes rook to h8
wesley could also try something like g4
and completely
try and close over the position and then
allow maybe magnus to play rook to h1
and maybe it's possible maybe if you
just keep everything blocked maybe you
will survive this but he decided to play
it actively
he played rook to h8 but now we have f
captures and g5
we have rook to h2 and now queen to f3
so what do you play here uh magnus just
gave up the d4 pawn so wesley grabs it
there's not nothing better here knight
capture is now attacking the queen
queen captures on the e5 and knight back
to c6 and here
uh magnus has a few ways of of playing
this
uh for example you could try something
like kink to g1 this is a very tricky
move
and now after the rook moves now you can
play knight to f4 and it's a very
hard position to play for black there
there's not not much you can do here
but instead we have e6 by magnus now
cutting off the queen
from the game also now you can pick up
the f5 pawn and it's much easier for
your pieces to get into the attack
so queen to d8 now wesley offers a queen
trade and the magnus
now well he accepts but he accepts under
his own terms he plays queen to d7
with check so now what do you play you
have to capture the queen otherwise
you're just going to start losing
material here
so queen captures we have pawn captures
and rook to d8 now preparing to
eliminate this spawn
but now magnus just defends it rook to
d2 and this is still a backward spawn
you will not be able to defend this so
here
knight to e5 uh and now comes just
rook captures on b7 there is nothing you
can do here
we have king to g6 by wesley and here
magnus played
rook captures on c7 and he was in this
position on move
uh 44 that wesley saw resigned in the
game and
with this uh the entire uh well uh
finals match so after uh such such an
excruciating uh task of facing all of
these players one after another magnus
was finally able to face
wesley in the finals uh and win because
if you remember
uh the the two of them all this is their
third encounter in the finals uh
and uh the first time that magnus won
wesley won the two the first two
so i thought uh it'd be uh well it'd be
so impressive for wesley
uh to win the third one then then like i
said we really have to question
uh magnus's a ability to
uh you know exact uh his dominance as
the world champion
uh but yeah magnus one here so uh
very very nicely done congratulations on
this amazing achievement and it wasn't
it wasn't easy because every time he
would win and then wesley would bounce
back and that's
not an easy thing you know usually
when magnus starts with a win uh most
players just collapse there are of
course a few
few top players that are able to
withstand the pressure but wesley always
withstands the pressure and uh like he's
shown here
that was pretty awesome uh but yeah in
the blitz section it was a wesley who
started with a win and then magnus
bounced back so that was also
uh really really crazy but yeah here you
resign because uh there's not
much you can do you're down material and
uh to give you an example for example
king captures on g5 we could grab this
but now
rook to d6 now we're going to eliminate
this pawn create another pass pawn we
already have this passport on this past
pawn
there is not much you can do black would
have to trade for example and then
we happily trade captures captures and
now play c6
and that's it the two pass pawns are now
connected after
white plays black plays something let's
say king g6 starts bringing the king
into the game
we're going to play rook to c8 now just
offer a trade of rooks because if black
doesn't agree to this we're going to
capture his rook
and otherwise uh that that's just it are
we bring a queen into the game if knight
f7 we can just trade trade and play this
and that's it whatever the night
wherever the knight moves we're just
going to bring a queen into the game
then the second queen yeah and so on
uh so congratulations to magnus on
winning the entire event
um so uh very very nicely done
uh wesley also played incredibly
impressive and uh
uh this is uh i mean it is just uh it's
just
incredibly enjoyable to be able to uh to
get such uh
such uh such a treat to watch these
players and you know just brawl it out
and there
there was like they played seven games
two of them were draws i mean it's
pretty crazy with uh four decisive games
and then a decisive armageddon
uh but yeah i once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
fergus duncan kiran madev
francis a i i uh andreas rosenthal and
jd chipokoti for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and uh have an excellent rest of
your day